alors christine vous allez reprendre le
rôle de lucrèce borgia pas leur crainte
je vous allez le prendre avec jean-luc
dans une mise en scène de jean-luc vous
prenez commence justement je le prends
bien mais encore je le prends très très
bien pour l'instant
bon on a commencé à travailler il ya pas
très longtemps alors peut-être scellé
jour face mais bon c'est peut-être du
plastique je touche du bois
c'est du bois ça va bien non non ça va
bien on a commencé il ya très peu de
temps vous venez de commencer les
répétitions
we will étions là bas mais oui c'était
voter oui
un petit bout de répétition oui mais
alors ces textes en main vraiment ça les
ai bien eus travail d'acteur ça commence
par la lecture des textes nous ep nous
et p
vous êtes chez moi il y à là je vous
tous
tous les meubles étaient immunisées
selon adrian vous le dit aujourd'hui
avec l'époux vente
oui vous pouvez me regarder avec vos
yeux de sa terreur c'est bien moi
monsieur je viens vous annoncer une
nouvelle c'est que vous êtes tous en
cloisonné et qu'il n'y en a pas un
d'entre vous qui est encore une arme à
feu dans la salle d'à côté et plein de
petits coeurs
à moi maintenant à mon tour
à moi de m'arrêter au et de vous écraser
la tête du bouddha oui c'est triste
alors voilà c'était un bout de
répétition texte en main de lucrèce
borgia
oui ça devait être la sixième ou
septième répétition
je voudrais quand même pas que oui mais
saracens et comme un objet comme ils
disent les psychanalystes n'achète pas
transitionnelle machin truc un objet
trop un objet concret enfants des autres
sans gardons cas je le garde à côté du
lit ce qu'il va dire que je le regarde
[Musique]